serve youtubers non so bene come
iniziare il discorso quindi loro inizio
e basta mercoledì scorso
premessa il mercoledì non lavoro e il
mio giorno libero quindi di solito una
volta al mese da un anno e mezzo a
questa parte quel mercoledì me lo prendo
per dedicarlo al cento per cento alle
recensioni
mercoledì scorso avrei dovuto fare la
recensione di novembre avevo film pronto
però purtroppo la mediaset l'ha tolto
perché è un film appunto della mediaset
e c'era su youtube era tolto non è il
problema che l'abbia top da youtube
il problema è che se ha tolto il film
probabilmente toglierebbe anche la mia
recessione non è stato tanto un problema
quello perché ho comunque una scorta di
film su cui lavorare
ne prende un altro ma arriva mercoledì e
cosa succede
io quel giorno lì non ho neanche
sfiorato lontanamente il film perché
perché chissà quali altri cavoli per la
testa levo non avevo tempo dovuto
offrire altre cose valle non è vero
niente quelle erano scuse che mi
inventavo io per me stesso che mi si
vedrà la mia testa per allontanarsi dal
fatto e dall'unica verità che non ho
avuto voglia e questa sensazione ci ho
già da molto tempo
il fatto di non avere voglia di mettermi
lì a fare una recensione questa cosa
porta porta al fatto che io ogni mese
devo obbligarmi a fare una recensione
che magari viene fuori male magari viene
fuori bene per l'amor di dio però
rischia di venir fuori male perché io
non ho voglia di farla e ripeto questa è
una sensazione che ho già da un po di
mesi addirittura ed è qui che vi dico
che le recensioni probabilmente smettono
aspettate questo non vuol dire che
chiude il canale assolutamente no vuol
dire che le recensioni il tipo di video
recensione film bla bla bla smetteranno
e voi non avete idea di quanto sia stato
difficile sia tutta adesso mentre sto
parlando difficile accettare il fatto
che probabilmente le recensioni se non
uno o due volte all'anno quando magari
sai c'è un effetto tipo halloween o tipo
natale non le farò più questo perché non
ho più voglia
non ho più la voglia di fare le
recensioni
io parto col dirvi che il canale youtube
ripeto non chiuderà poi aspettate a dire
che non chiuderà il canale aspettate
alla fine che vi dico cose nuove e tra
l'altro è chiedo scusa ha probabilmente
avete visto un cambiamento della qualità
del video perché il nostro più
registrato con la stessa telecamera ma
ho cambiato telecamera ma anche questo è
lo spiego dopo aspettate un attimo
io ho aperto il mio canale 7 anni fa
2000 attestato 2006 sette anni fa quasi
8 ormai in questo vuol dire tanto
sette anni di videos tutti sede sempre
dello stesso stile in realtà io ho
iniziato come sapete bene facendo
cortometraggi facendo sketch comici e
poi buttandoci dentro anche delle
recensioni che sono andate molto bene
quindi ovviamente ho seguito il filone
che comunque io ho sempre fatto le cose
perché esprimevano la mini umorismo e le
recensioni le solo esprimevano
abbastanza bene
che poi si sono evolute moltissimo prima
erano molto più naturali adesso sono un
po più impostate ma secondo me
funzionano meglio eccetera eccetera ma
questi sono sette anni di lavori 7 io
non so che molta gente mi segue magari
dice ti seguo da tantissimo e mi segue
da 34 anni che sono un'infinità
ma io faccio video da sette anni e
faccio sempre gli stessi video da sette
anni alcune recensioni oggi sono più
altre non arriveranno più ma fatto sta
che gli anni rimangono sette la mia
fortuna con il canale con voi è stata
che lo sapete meglio di me con gli anni
le cose tendono a scemare un po pubblico
tende ad allontanarsi un po ea cambiare
tipologie di video da guardare
non è stato così per niente con le
recensioni
io ho raggiunto i 400 mila e dopo vi
ringrazio per questo ma non è mai non è
mai andato sotto i 400 mila le
visualizzazioni e fare il numero di
visualizzazioni uguale al numero degli
iscritti è follia follia e io quindi non
posso far altro che ringraziarli per
tutti questi anni di visualizzazioni
altissime altissime ci sono stati
periodi tipo due anni fa dove facevo
molte più visualizzazioni che iscritti
molti di più a francia tipo il doppio
delle visualizzazioni rispetto agli
iscritti e questa è una cosa di cui vado
di qui son contenti cio di cui vado
fiero perché alla fine magari non
piacciono al 8 a tutti i video però sono
contento che insomma alla fine sia
andato bene tutto quanto scusatemi se
mio papino ma non mi sono preparato
niente perché difficile un log difficile
questo è niente questo è le recensioni
non continueranno semplicemente perché
non ho più la voglia di farle ma e
ripeto per l'ennesima volta non vuol
dire che non abbia più voglia di fare i
video
io non ho più voglia di fare recensioni
quel tipo di video io ho voglia di
cambiare
ho voglia di cambiare e cambiare non
vuol dire mettere un poster nuovo non
vuol dire mettere uno sfondo nuovo no
vuol dire cambiare io mi sono illuso che
ho detto magari cambiando perché io
giusto due video fa vettore arrivata la
nuova stagione di recensioni perché mi
illudevo che magari ricominciando da
zero mi sarebbe venuta la voglia ma in
realtà non è stato così
quindi è inutile prenderci per il culo
ben sapete quanto è difficile qui c'è io
spero che voi capiate che chiudere una
serie di video che fa quel genere di
visualizzazioni e dargli un [ __ ] t e
voi e molta gente perché questo discorso
sto facendo un po nelle live un po in
altri posti
me lo avete detto c'è gente che ha detto
ma tu sei un [ __ ] ma proprio
cattivone detto tu sei un [ __ ] che
il caso è ancora non è solo un [ __ ]
però sono un [ __ ] che ha preso una
scelta e cerca di rispettarla
tra l'altro io ho vissuto in questi due
anni di tra l'altro io ho vissuto in
questi due anni di boom
grazie anche i soldi della partnership
ormai non mi devo neanche spiegare cos'è
la partnership che si guadagni eccetera
eccetera
io ho vissuto parzialmente grazie a
quello parzialmente grazie al lavoro ma
buona parte è stato anche da youtube
quindi voi mi avete aiutato a vivere
semplicemente a vivere a campare facendo
quello che vi piace cioè facendo video
però c'è un
diciamo che è meglio vedere come si dice
finire una cosa nel suo piccolo che vede
la colare a picco quindi preferisco
quasi finirla finire qui non proprio
perché ci sarà la recensione di natale
che sarà l'ultima recensione che
chiuderà tutta la storyline che non c'è
mai stato la storia è però chiuderà
tutta la storyline delle recensioni poi
ripeto ci saranno recensioni qui e là
magari ad halloween dell'anno prossimo
in qualche evento qualche caso la pasqua
natale
non lo so non lo so non lo so non ne ho
idea
però no però ecco il punto focale su cui
voglio concentrarmi che non chiudo al
canale e non smetto di fare video tra
l'altro ringrazio e non voglio che
pensiate che per il canale di gaming
no il canale di leinì sta andando alla
grande e io vi abbraccio tutti ci stiamo
divertendo insieme da morire voi lo
sapete meglio di me non
chi non sta seguendo tranquillissimi non
non è che mi state prendendo chissà cosa
però non è per quello quello è una cosa
che ho voluto fare appunto che non è
strano non sta né che trasformando in in
più sta quasi diventando un mio secondo
canale principale mali e in un altro
discorso è staccato da questo canale non
è per quello che non faccio più
recensioni per niente scordatevelo non è
per quello neanche morire c'è gente che
lo dice potete pensarlo se volete ma non
è per quello quello lì non mi prende
così tanto tempo anche se sanno
benissimo quindi io vi ringrazio
tantissimo sempre stato il mio sogno tra
l'altro farlo e avere un canale da
gestire una cosa bellissima
ci sia divertendo a morire il canale
principale però io voglio mandarlo
avanti perché io a me piace parlare di
film comunque ho voglia di creare un
nuovo format che o ci ho pensato in
questi giorni su cosa creare cosa fare e
alla fine non è che ci siano tanti
formati da fare prendo un film e ne
parlo semplicemente ovvio però non è non
è come adesso che io ti recensisco il
film
analizzandolo trama c'è un tassello per
passarlo dall'altra ma assolutamente no
il format si chiamerà mostarda qui mi è
venuto in mente mentre stavo arrivando
in ufficio ha tra l'altro a proposito
l'ufficio probabilmente ci saluterà
anche lui per un semplice fatto che
nella mia vita stanno cambiando un sacco
di cose tra lavoro la casa perché io sto
cercando casa e probabilmente i primi
mesi del 2014 mi trasferirò e siccome
dovrò pagare l'affitto di pagare
l'affitto dell'ufficio non mi sembra il
caso visto che potrei fare video
tranquillamente la quindi probabilmente
il bear ufficio qui ci saluterà dove
puoi fare un video a dovere il capitano
non affonda non abbandona mai la da
suonare prima che affondi
e questo era per dirvi che appunto il
l'ufficio ci salutò perso il filo
roberto sto dicendo cagate perché ho
perso il filo il format si chiamerà
mostarda perché mostarda ripeto
volutamente mentre camminavo qua chi mi
segue per bene lo sa che io adoro i
monologhi di luttazzi e lui ha fatto un
monologo tre anni fa ha chiamato bollito
misto con mostarda che era una
similitudine diciamo per dire che il
bollito misto sarebbe argomenti vari la
mostarda e l'umorismo la satira il
proprio come sia l'acidità e siccome io
non faccio proprio un bollito misto
quindi tolgo bollito misto e lascia la
mostarda però sarà così io parlerò di
film in questo modo qua in modo ironico
me ho sempre fatto come sempre fatto nei
blog come sempre fatto nei video che non
sono le recessioni sempre parla nei live
di tutti questi giorni sempre in modo
ironico sempre in modo quasi di satira
po particolare ma è proprio vero e
proprio satira però è una sorta di
umorismo un po tagliente appunto stronzo
diciamo così e mi piacerebbe farlo
parlando di film e di tutti quei film
che non ho mai potuto fare porca eva
perché coperti da dirti che mi avrebbero
chiuso il canale altro che finire le
recensioni avrebbe completamente chiuso
carai tipo no non faccio spoiler
no è probabilmente il secondo canale
verrà chiuso nel senso che prenderò
tutti i video il secondo canale e man
mano l'icarico qua ma magari non me li
faccio proprio vedere nel senso che non
voglio caricarmi per poi guadagnare su
soldi che ho folk su un substrato su
video che ho fatto vecchi no non mi
sembra il caso e verrà chiuso perché
tanto i blog tutte le altre cagate
verranno messe qui insieme a mostarda e
quindi l'altro canale mi sembra inutile
tenere tre canali no chiudiamo un canale
ma questo è un addio non per me a voi
che mi continuerete seguire ma per tutti
gli altri che ovviamente
in modo molto normale ve lo dico proprio
come se lo sapessi già che molta gente
non mi servirà più perché mi ha
conosciuto con le recensioni ha seguito
sempre solo le recensioni
giustamente perché il mio format era
quello e quindi smettendo le recensioni
probabilmente ci vedremo una volta
l'hanno neanche quella volta l'anno e io
dal profondo del mio cuore non posso
altro che ringraziarvi per tutti questi
anni incredibili perché sono stati anni
incredibili incazzature di di gioie di
di traguardi
questo è un traguardo i 400mila sono
un'enorme traguardo e io ho voluto farlo
adesso per non prendere il veicolo dopo
semplicemente per quello
so che stupido a raggiungere i 400 mila
e mollare il format che ti ha portato i
400mila ma è così che deve andare a
seconda della mia testa è così che deve
andare
quindi io non dico che vi invito ad
iscrivervi con il cuore per con affetto
non sto dicendo se non volete più
seguire me e siete liberissimi un easy
iscrivervi a dal canale perché è giusto
e giù e nella legge della natura to
smetti ti seguono per una è come se tu
andassi dal macellaio di fiducia perché
fa le bistecche più buone del mondo tu
fai e poi quando lui raggiunge un gran
numero dice sai cosa non ho più voglia
di fare di bistecche facciamo cereali
no quindi alla gente cosa che diceva io
volevo le bistecche me ne vado però
magari qui cereali sono buoni o magari
farà a cagare come i miei video magari
saranno belli magari mi piace ma in
realtà non è che non vi piaceranno non
vi piacevano perché saranno recensioni
in realtà l'umorismo sempre quello è se
non un po più un po chiusura proprio
mostarda
diciamo che quello che vuole fare alla
fine saranno dei piccoli monologhi
comici dove probabilmente non mi farò
e anche vedere parte del le parti del
film perché uno non posso due non è così
che io voglio farlo come se fosse un
piccolo monologo che è sempre quello che
ho sognato di fare sempre sempre sognato
di fare quello
quindi arrivederci
e stato molto bello di quelli che non mi
seguiranno più e io non posso fare altro
che ringraziarli proprio dal profondo
del mio cuore probabilmente questo
momento sarà ci sarà una musichetta in
sottofondo sdolcinata strappalacrime
tipo i violent files con noi va in femme
con we feel in legno e divertirsi con
tutti quelli che non mi seguiranno più
che saranno una buona percentuale è
stata una bella corsa
siamo arrivati ad un traguardo
incredibile insieme con tutti gli altri
ci vediamo allora fra credo fra una
ventina di giorni il video di natale
dall'anno prossimo mostarda più
cortometraggi tutto quello che volevo
fare prima cortometraggi comici lavora a
lavorare con la comicità con tutti i
tipi di comicità mai le parodie con le
parrucche però mai se finisco a fare
parodie con le parrucche video
l'indirizzo di casa mia mi prendete a
ginocchiate dei [ __ ] e nelle gengive
e con tutto rispetto per chi fa i video
con le parrucche un saluto di quel punto
lo fanno in tanti ea me piacciono però
io non sono capace
e se lo faccio a sparatemi e niente
quindi
ci vediamo dall'altra parte dello
specchio